hey guys I'm Ryan I'm Kat I'm Jerry
memory yo we got a cool assembly line
going on I've had like 89 people tell me
today you gotta watch the rise of
electro trailer no joke I left work
early made up a bunch of [ __ ] just
so I could get home and watch this damn
trailer cuz I was like I feel pressured
and then I invited all these guys to
come along with me
I really hope nobody from your work they
don't my work does not care anything
about my youtube channel I'm excited for
it I've already seen like a billion
things of this and I'm jacked up that
enemies United trailer [ __ ] sexiest
[ __ ] have all you guys seen the first
spider-man oh no yeah Oh Marie really
ruined it every out of the sibley line
apparently this is about electro Jamie
Foxx's character this is like the most
exciting trailer so far this year now
yeah Michael J Fox alright what not
electro oh I get it
the Jamie Foxx thing yeah I thought you
were making a par Michaels disease
you're five all right guys you ready to
start web-slinging I am ready oh gosh
okay
oh my god wow that was awesome
it's really honed his skills hasn't you
yeah lassies had some time to work on
marble do the effects look amazing uh ha
and probably deserve from ores apart
Terry ah so for my father you spend more
time watching you than me
why is enough question of the day
secret until the truth does - we have
plans for you Peter Parker [ __ ] oh it's
Ray Charles I like the music I like the
music
it's a four-stage
like me
damn and that seems like a [ __ ]
villain right there as is cool
des awesome sweet ah always got time for
a jim-dandy action shot incredibly well
looks like a sick ring good
what if something happens you cuz of me
I wonder if he dies in this one
this movie is gonna kick so much ass
yeah
there's blue of time wait oh ah the
chills
damn IMAX yes it's all about IMAX that's
gonna be badass that looks incredible
yeah they're promoting this film so
[ __ ] well rarely do I actually bother
to watch all the trailers and movie
clips of a movie that's getting released
every single time I watch it something
for it I get jacked up
testosterone fuel footage - I mean you
know they've lots of work yes
yeah the footage is included and the
thing I'm talking about yeah like the
time square see it's amazing one thing
that really blown me blow me away that
blew me away I'm gonna say that you one
day one thing I really blew me away was
the way the action is shot like it
always looked cool but it seemed like
Marc Webb really improved his direction
over this and how cool is it that Marc
Webb has the last name Webb he's born to
direct this film he was born to direct
this am the entire life has been waiting
up in this moment and I'm so happy they
got like great actors for all these
roles I got Jamie Foxx's electro Dondi
han has Dane DeHaan denotes Dondi Han
they got him as like emo Harry Osborn he
was that like creepy looking
[ __ ] yeah it's kind of like the
creepy homosexual looking [ __ ]
you know there's nothing wrong be
glorious Gary but I love gay people no
yeah I do don't [ __ ] say that I'm not
saying you know anything I'm terrified
of gay people because they're all creepy
little emo murderers um oh that's a
place David died - I'm really happy that
we got this on cam right so spider-man's
cool yes fire max cool right now I
really want to go back and watch the
first spider-man movies and I gotta
admit I do prefer Andrew Garfield as
spider-man I do yeah he just gives more
life - yeah there's more layers I see
okay
oh I think he's different no I like a
jerk a [ __ ] I like Andrew Garfield I
just think he's different the Tobey
Maguire versions a lot more the more
sort of reserved shy a nerdy guy yeah
whereas Peter Parker and this one is
like yeah sure he's getting us but he's
yeah he's like he just had a can of Red
Bull oh yeah he doesn't seem like a geek
to me at all like he's today's teenager
who happens to be smart with science
yeah I mean he built those webs that
he's like going around which I still
have a hard time buying is that the well
he took
his dad's design and made it tiny ah
good point jer-bear good point you have
changed my opinion yeah
Rai Rai I want to cool in a game plus
you get let's color puzzle stop [ __ ] I
changed my mind until he anyway
this video is gonna hand I just wanted
to say thank you guys for all your
suggestions on this trailer I've [ __ ]
loved it and yeah just more I never know
what to watch because there's just so
many and yes you subscribers are awesome
you see this button up here click it if
you haven't subscribed yet click on Z
click it there's more videos like this
hot one click it on here and those
videos are marine